for the first time there was an election
for the eu's top job
social democrat martin schultz and
conservative jean-claude juncker faced
off in tv debates during the campaign
the winner's task would be to sell the
idea of europe to a largely
disillusioned populace
schultz lost the vote but stayed on as
president of the european parliament
while yunka became european commission
president
he and his team were faced with winning
over hearts and minds
and pulling europe's economy out of the
doldrums
we've decided that we'll be
concentrating on the most important
issues
in the first months of the new
commission
because we don't think every problem in
europe is also a problem for the
european union
and the european commission there's a
wind of change blowing
but it won't be a storm
but there was a storm soon afterwards a
storm of controversy
as newspapers detailed luxembourg's
status as a tax haven for companies
the investigation became known as lux
leaks
the country's questionable policies and
loopholes were the responsibility of the
then prime minister
jean-claude juncker
there were other problems too protests
like this one in belgium showed people's
opposition to austerity policies
the economy remained stalled
unemployment
caused in part by austerity measures
remained high
and many voters turned away from the
idea of europe
euroskeptic parties found new support in
2014
in france the far-right national front
headed by marine le pen
actually won european elections
alongside the internal problems there
was also crisis at europe's door
the conflict in ukraine and russia's
annexation of crimea
eu leaders ordered sanctions against
russia citing european values
germany's chancellor saw the move as a
sign of increased
unity in the bloc despite all the debate
about this
i think we've dealt with it well think
how europe was in the face of the iraq
war
it was split in two now it's been
possible to stay united
both within europe and with our
transatlantic partners
that's also thanks to a u.s president
who looks towards europe
and is interested in what happens here
that's a huge value in itself
the cooling relations with russia gave
new relevance to nato
and its new secretary general against
stoltenberg
at a meeting in wales nato members voted
to form a rapid reaction force to be
able to better respond to any escalation
of the ukraine crisis
this came amid reports of nato
identifying russian military aircraft
close to the airspace of member states
proof of the organization's worth said
stoltenberg
and of course i never welcome a more
dangerous world
that's that's uh but but but the
increased
focus on nato reflects that
we once again see how important
nato is that we need a strong alliance
being able to protect and defend all
allies
there were new concerns about the middle
east as conflict and lawlessness in iraq
and syria enabled the is militia to
capture territory
and install a reign of terror tens of
thousands of refugees from the middle
east and from africa fled to europe
eu states were ill-prepared for such an
influx in germany refugee centers are
overflowing
but many don't even make it the un says
nearly three and a half thousand
migrants died crossing the mediterranean
this year
italy's mari nostrum program rescued
more than 150
000 migrants from the mediterranean but
that program
won't continue into 2015. instead
there's a new european program
triton but it covers a smaller section
of the sea
there could be more maritime tragedies
involving migrants in 2015.
the eu will face tough challenges in the
year ahead
member states will have to unite to
solve europe's problems
even though many europeans are more
apathetic than ever
about the idea of european unity